[Music]
historically kings queens and emperors
have tried to find the Fountain of Youth
they failed Ponce de Leon instead found
dead Florida emperor qin of china
apparently he sent his princes to look
for the Fountain of Youth with the order
if you don't find the Fountain of Youth
don't come back and apparently he found
in Japan and he founded Korea as a
consequence of that so we have a long
history of people searching for the
Fountain of Youth without success at all
in fact the tales of Gilgamesh perhaps
one of the oldest written tales
predating parts of the Bible the tale of
Gilgamesh well he had a mission and his
mission was to find a secret of
immortality so today we have two kinds
of immortality digital immortality and
genetic biologic immortality digital
immortality I think we will attain it is
an attainable goal and that is to
digitize our entire life one day when
you go to the library instead of getting
a book about Winston Churchill you'll
talk to Winston Churchill you'll see a
holographic image of him that has all
the mannerisms the speeches and many of
the memories of Winston Churchill in
fact one of these days your descendants
your descendants could go to a library
and talk to you because you have been
digitized
I mean think of your credit card
transactions for example if I know your
credit card transactions all right I
already know where do you like to
vacation what kinds of wines you like to
buy and drink what you like to do in
your spare time think of what happens if
I have the totality the totality of your
digital fingerprint all the videos all
the vacations everything perhaps I can
create a reasonable facsimile of you and
then of course the question is is that
really you well to paraphrase former
President Bill Clinton it all depends on
how you define you if you define you
as the biological entity with your
memories then of course it is not you
but if you define your soul as entropy
and information that is if you say that
your soul is information that evolves
with time via the laws of entropy then
you can be digitized
because your soul is digital the other
immortality of course is biologic and
genetic immortality we have artificial
intelligence systems that can scan
tremendous amount of data to look for
patterns so in the future we will take
the genomes of millions of old people
and the genome of millions of young
people run them through an AI system
that look for patterns where is error
concentrated which genes control the
aging process for example take a car
wait is aging take place in a car well
that's obvious right
most of the aging takes place in the
engine because that's where you have
moving parts that's where you have
combustion oxidation that's where all
the action takes place well in a cell
where is the engine of a cell it is the
mitochondria and where do we find air
buildup entropy building up in a cell
and that is the mitochondria so bingo we
now know more or less where to look when
you look for the buildup of error in a
cell because that's what aging is aging
is the build-up of air cellular air
biological air and genetic air air
entropy
that's what aging is now if you take a
look at the Greenland shark the
Greenland shark has one of the world's
records for a vertebrate that lives so
long you can barely measure it by
looking at the eye the eye of the
Greenland shark you're looking at the
layers they add layers once a year just
like tree rings and you can actually
date the life of a Greenland shark the
ones they've looked at so far are over
400 years old and so we already have
examples of vertebrates that have
lifespans far beyond anything that
we humans can can muster now we also
have other clues we know that telomerase
for example can quote stop the clock we
have a clock in our cells call telomers
they get shorter and shorter after every
cell reproduction after a certain point
they simply unravel thus the chromosomes
of the cell and the cell goes into
senescence and eventually dies that is
the biological clock skin cells for
example reproduce about 60 times
approximately 60 times that's the
hayflick limit for a skin cell but in
Miller Park California they've
immortalized these cells we can now take
ordinary human skin cells apply
telomerase on them and they stop the
clock they simply reproduce forever now
what's the catch there's always a catch
someplace right the catch is that cancer
cells also use telomerase on the way to
immortality you see cancer cells are
immortal that's why they kill you why
are cancer cells so dangerous are they
poisonous do they have toxins do they
eat up ordinary cells no they just live
forever and they populated until they
form a tumor and the tumor kills you so
in other words telomerase is one of the
mechanisms used by cancer cells to
immortalize themselves and we've
isolated it and perhaps one day we will
be able to use things like polymerase in
order to extend our lifespan in addition
to that we found all sorts of enzymes
that are involved in the oxidation
process for example the Greenland shark
why does it live so long
well the short answer is we don't know
but there's a theory that says the
Greenland shark lives near Greenland
where it's cold very cold where
oxidation takes place at a much lower
level than for us mammals had at living
in North America for example and so this
means that perhaps by controlling the
oxidation process we can duplicate what
the Greenland shark has done and the
Greenland shark lives for over 400 years
of age and the point I'm making is very
simple we do not have the Fountain of
Youth
however I think it's only a matter of
time before perhaps our grandkids have
the option of maybe reaching the age of
30 and stopping we may be able to stop
the clock we may like to be around 30
because we still have our youthful vigor
and we're not a little bit more mature
we may want to stop the clock at that
point that cannot be ruled out
unfortunately it's not perhaps for my
generation my generation maybe in fact
the last generation the dye generations
after this generation may have the
option of stopping the clock
[Music]